Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the
Roundtable of Dim Lighting
we are going to be talking all
about our new television show
"Inside Eats With Rhett
& Link" on Food Network
and this isn't.
And Discovery+.
This isn't like a,
I mean we're obviously gonna
be talking about the show
and all our other things that we do
and trying to get you to watch it.
This is not a promotion.
This is not
a promotional thing.
This is a, we're two guys.
You know us, Rhett and Link.
We're friends, we own a company together
and we try to make things
happen in the media landscape
and one of the exciting things
that's happening for us personally
is this television show.
So we're gonna
kind of get into it.
Yeah if you care enough
about us to care about the
stuff that we care about,
well it turns out we,
we're pretty excited about this you know?
I mean we've had a few
milestones in our career
that were television shows.
Yeah.
We had one Online Nation
in 2000 and what, nine, eight?
Seven.
Wow.
I just kind of guessed.
You know, you're my safety
net of numbers and time.
2007 and then Commercial Kings on IFC.
You can get this one.
2010?
Nope, 2011.
Oh .
Are you serious?
Like 2011 is the year we
moved to California because
of that television show.
Yeah man.
Yeah, so many memories.
Almost 11 years.
So many memories.
Well we're gonna be talking
about how does this happen.
2021, we got another one.
How does one find themselves
on a television show
and then what happens when you begin to
produce said television show.
What are the steps in this process
and what did we learn and how did we feel?
I will say promotionally
speaking that the first episode
is out.
I mean depending on when
you're listening to this,
more may be out.
But 10:30 on Sunday
nights on Food Network.
Oh, because if you're
listening to this super fresh,
like the day this episode drops
it was last night was the premiere right?
Is that right?
Oh snap.
That sounds right.
Yeah,
'cause this comes out
on a Monday typically.
Yeah.
Yeah so 10:30 Sunday nights.
And I was wearing this shirt
in the premiere episode,
I just thought I'd do that.
Oh, there you go.
I thought I'd make it interesting.
A little in session.
The Discovery+ versions
are extended versions.
Slightly extended versions
of the same episodes.
So it's not bonus footage.
It's.
It's because you.
Some of the scenes are extended.
You don't have to fit into the.
There's some extra stuff in there if
you're watching on Discovery+.
The half hour time slot
for TV.
So yeah, I'm also ready to party.
Just as a side note.
I see you got your party suit on.
You see that?
I've got my new party suit.
Yeah like, you kind of
look like a guy that was
just cleaning a floor.
Right, I could be working.
But he's like, is he gonna,
is he cleaning up after us?
Or does he own the company?
I mean.
Yeah.
And people can't see the,
can't see.
The fact that it matches.
It matches, the bottoms match.
It is a suit.
It is a janitorial suit.
Good Lord, what happened?
Why is this here?
Good God.
Well, where did you pick that up?
Instagram.
I do all my shopping on Instagram man.
Shout out to Imperfects.
Is what this is called.
Are you gonna button it up later?
'Cause if you button it up,
you look like you're
ready to start mopping.
Imma button it up when
I get to work tonight
on the turntables.
Yeah we have a party tonight.
We have.
Christmas party.
So we have not been able to
come together as a company,
as the greater umbrella of Mythicals.
Everybody at Mythical, everybody at Smosh.
We wanted to obviously have
a holiday party in 2020,
that didn't happen.
We obviously wanted it to happen
in 2021.
Well we planned
the Christmas party.
In 2021, we planned a Christmas party
and then the week before
it, Omicron just like.
Yeah.
Went buck wild.
Just butt wild.
So we.
I thought,
for the longest time I
thought it was butt wild.
I think you can say that.
That means a different thing.
We were gonna go, Halloween.
Christmas holiday butt wild.
And everybody.
Might have been throwing
some Halloween.
We were gonna do a horror-themed
sweater competition.
So it wasn't just your typical.
Horror.
You just said horror-themed.
It was horror-themed
'cause I pay attention to the prompts.
I knew we were judging it.
I know we had a TV show in 2007, 2011
and now 2022.
2011, yep.
So do I now.
And we also,
for the 2021 holiday party,
the prompt was to do a
horror-themed crazy sweater
'cause we didn't want
to do an ugly sweater
because that's like five years ago right?
That's pre-pandemic y'all.
Is he right about this?
So a Christmas horror
though, not Halloween horror.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
That's what makes it cool.
Well we're not doing that tonight.
We told them to save
it for next Christmas party.
Right
but in our meeting the other day
when we were talking
about this Christmas party
or the spring party, Emily was like,
"Can we bring our?"
She apparently worked
very hard on her sweater.
'Cause we said there was
a cash prize.
She was like,
"Can I bring my sweater?"
And I was like,
"I know a lot of you worked very hard
"on your horror-themed sweaters.
"I am very excited to see them.
"But please hold them until
the 2022 holiday party."
So at the end of the year we get to,
hopefully they won't be too dusty.
Things are gonna break on their
horror sweaters, I'm sure.
'Cause people build them,
you know they didn't
build them for a year.
They built them to use that night
and now they're like hanging up somewhere.
You forget where it is by the time
the next Christmas party rolls around.
But yeah we're gonna.
And we're gonna
change the theme.
It'll be not scary.
It'll be like happy sweaters.
No, but we'll stop
to give away the.
Encouraging sweaters.
Cash prize.
People really stepped up for that I think.
Yeah.
And then we had to can it.
So how do you,
I do wanna check in and
see how you feel about,
because I have anxiety about this
and if I have anxiety about this,
then you have even more reason
to have anxiety about this.
We have not been with all these people.
Oh.
And there's like 125 plus of them
that are gonna be at this
party who work at Mythical.
We've hired a bunch of people
over the course of the past two years.
I don't know what percentage
of them I have actually met.
Yeah.
Out of the percentage
that I have actually met,
I don't know how many I
would be able to recognize
with seeing the bottom half of their face
and then remember their name.
Jen, are we doing name tags?
We're doing name tags?
Yes.
I requested that
yesterday because of this.
Right.
How big are the name tags gonna be?
Are they gonna be so big
that people can't tell that
you're looking at them?
Oh yeah.
We need to do like.
Like cleavage size?
No, we need to do like
Second Life type things.
Oh it's hovering.
Where it's a name tag
that hovers above your
head, very, very large.
So people can't really tell
if you're looking in their eye
or looking at their name tag.
I love it.
Do we have time to do that
in the next eight hours?
Yeah I think maybe my suggestion
would be some sort of like,
like an old hangar.
Like old hangars, secured with duct tape
to the shoulders.
Oh.
They come up above the top.
If everybody would do that
before the party, it'll be great.
Hey, you know I'm with you man
'cause I have that name fright.
Oh yeah.
I saw it begin to emerge
in the company-wide meeting the other day.
Yeah.
When you pointed
at one person and said a different name.
Yeah, I was like.
I was recognizing Ammo
for his, his promotion
and I pointed at Zach.
Yeah.
I mean listen brother.
It's hard.
And then I said,
"If you squint, you guys look alike."
And I don't know if that made it better.
Yeah, I mean yeah you should probably
have kept that to yourself.
I don't know man.
So yeah, I was a little nervous about that
but I know we're doing the
nametags so I'm cool with that.
And I, I am DJing this party.
Oh I heard that.
Did, oh that's why you
were wearing the outfit.
But I don't like, yeah
that's my DJ outfit.
But I don't,
and my name is DJ Rhett by the way.
Well okay, hold on now.
Your name is DJ Straw Beat.
No, my name is DJ Rhett.
I'm MC Sky and I may rap at
any point that I want to.
I did not name myself that
but I think it was our friend Jayden.
Like I was talking about,
liking to make playlists
and I think he,
I think it was an accident.
Like he's a close friend
so it rarely happens.
So when he called he said, DJ Rhett.
I think he was thinking my
name was Rhett for a second
and he had a brain fart.
Yep.
Even though he knows us
really well.
We didn't have our name tags
on at the time.
We like busted out laughing.
This was like three
years ago, pre-pandemic.
And we just busted out laughing
and he said from then on,
he stored my name in
his phone as DJ Rhett.
That's kind of funny man.
To kind of own the fact that he really,
royally screwed up.
Okay, all right.
DJ Rhett is.
By DJing you mean?
I'm still working on my DJ name but I'm.
You're creating a playlist
and then walking around in the party.
You're not staying
behind a booth?
I am not.
I'm not really DJing and I
don't want anybody to know
that I'm doing.
You're curating a playlist.
I'm curating the playlist
and I don't want anybody to know
that I have aspirations to be a DJ
because I don't want that to get out.
Will you have on your phone?
Because I don't have any DJ equipment.
In the moment.
Yet.
The ability to take requests
or to skip songs?
Hell no.
Well hold on, I'm not saying
did you have the willingness.
I said do you have the
ability to?
Oh.
Is your phone
going to be controlling the
playlist as you walk around?
On your person.
No.
Are you lying?
Yes it's a, yeah no.
I'm not, it's a laptop dude.
Are you lying, yes.
It's a laptop.
Well at least we're being honest.
You really can't, without
the proper equipment,
you can't really DJ.
I mean like making a playlist
is just a hack way to do it
because that's not
really, that's not DJing.
That's the only level of DJing
that I am actually comfortable
endorsing though really.
What do you mean?
For this party.
Endorsing?
Yeah I don't wanna seem
like I'm trying too hard.
We did a party one time
'cause we're doing it in the parking lot
and we did it before in the parking lot
and we had a real DJ who was at the thing.
Was at the booth, was at the turntables.
Yeah.
And I just felt like.
It was unmemorable.
It may have been too.
Yeah.
High key for us.
Ah, well I'm taking some risks.
Oh really?
Playing some controversial artists?
No, I'm going for a vibe
that I don't know that.
Oh.
People are going to be
expecting.
Too low key?
You think maybe it's too low key?
I think there's a risk of that.
I'm not risking going too hard.
Do you have just like Jim
Brickman just piano music?
No it's not, it's not gonna be.
Does everything have a beat?
No one's gonna go to sleep.
Everything has a beat.
But yeah the.
Do you have
an Audible playlist?
Like I can call on Audible?
Yeah.
Like change it.
Sorry, playing a book on tape.
Can you just start playing Sapiens?
Everyone loves that book.
Six o'clock this morning.
I got up and I was working on it.
I worked for an hour on
a backup, yeah in case.
Like a vibe change.
In case I was wrong, yeah.
I think that was really smart.
And then when I was driving in,
I came up with another backup.
So I'm trying to come up with.
Wow you got a backup to the backup?
Yeah, I just don't you know.
This is a learning process for me.
Well don't let people know that.
That's why I don't want anyone to know
that I'm actually doing the music at all.
Like I'm not even going,
imma be part of the party and
then I want someone to say,
"Oh I like this music."
Who made this playlist?
Yeah it's just who made the playlist?
Like I've said before.
And then you're gonna claim it.
There is no DJ.
I am not the DJ.
You're gonna say, "Well DJ Rhett did."
Yeah I am.
And then I'll just
acknowledge it and be like yeah.
You can't take, if people like
it, you can't take credit.
Well if you say that DJ Rhett.
DJ Rhett is not Rhett.
DJ Rhett is Link.
Well are you going to
explain that to everyone?
No unless it's going really, really well.
Is there going to be?
It's not about the music and
that's the vibe I've chosen.
It's not about the music,
it's about reconnecting with
everyone for the first time
in maybe ever?
Is there a microphone
and a PA system?
I don't, yeah there's.
It's not just going to be laptop speakers.
Well I know that, I just
wanna make sure that.
I do know very little though.
But this could be the end
of something.
Are we gonna be making
a speech is what I'm getting at.
Or the beginning of something.
Well that's your problem.
You worry about a speech.
Well no, that's the problem.
I want you to worry about the speech.
'Cause I don't want you
to be doing the speech.
No no no no.
In the moment.
I'm also going to be.
Because that's when
the party could go real sideways.
Yeah, 'cause I'm gonna be partying too.
Yeah.
I'm not in full work mode.
I'm just in work attire.
I'm not cleaning up
messes either but I could,
I could shave down a surfboard.
That's what I like to think this is like
a worker who works on
shaving down surfboards.
That's what the model.
I've watched,
I've watched a few of those videos.
Who was wearing this.
And I bought it.
And I've never seen that
be the case.
That's the guy was wearing it doing that
and I was like that's who I wanna be.
Let's talk about the television show
but first let's talk about something else.
Just wanna remind you,
there's other podcasts.
Trevor Talks Too Much is one of them.
His guests are surprising and delighting
and they connect with him.
You should give it a shot.
If you've never listened
to Trevor Talks Too Much
and while you're at it,
Best Friends Back Alright.
The Stevie-hosted podcast,
check that one out too
if you haven't already.
Totally different vibe
than Trevor Talks Too Much.
Kind of a similar vibe to what we do here.
Two friends connecting.
Yeah.
Over their past, getting nostalgic
about the 2000s in their case.
The friendship is blossoming.
If you're into that, a
blossoming friendship,
check that out.
And if you want to watch
our old television show
Commercial Kings.
Commercial Kings, can't say it right.
Yeah I'm gonna promote that too.
That's interesting.
You can watch it on Amazon.
Yep.
I believe it's
on Amazon Prime for free, could be wrong.
But I think that's right.
Just search Commercial
Kings with Rhett and Link
and catch up on our 2011 television show.
Yeah.
Okay, how does one get a television show?
This was not our idea.
So let's start there.
You know, we are developing lots of ideas
for all types of what we call
traditional entertainment.
That means movies, television shows
of the scripted variety
and also of the non-scripted variety.
Could be a game show,
could be a reality show.
It could be a mixture of both.
We're developing all types of stuff
because we're fans of ideas.
Especially our own.
Yep.
But we're also open to
other people's ideas
if they work for us.
Like Ronstadt is a great
scripted podcast idea
that did not originate with us
but it was really
exciting to get on board.
Right, so every once in awhile
people come along and say,
"Hey here's an opportunity
"for you guys to be
involved in this project."
And that's how this happened.
So there was a show that
was already in development
and not just in development,
like it had been greenlit by
Food Network to be a show.
As far as I remember, yeah.
But when you say in development,
I kind of feel like it was pitched.
They were like yes.
The concept at the time.
The working title was
"Inside Our Favorite".
Or "Inside Your Favorite".
I think it was "Inside Our Favorite".
Inside Our Favorite with dot dot dot
and our name was thrown
out in the pitch meetings.
Would Food Network, Discovery+.
What do you guys think
about Rhett and Link?
They could be perfect
hosts for this thing.
Inside Our Favorite.
You go behind the scenes into the.
The first way it was
talked about to us was.
The people.
Factories where all these people
were working behind the scenes
on factory lines to create your
favorite snacks and candies,
things like that.
So it was kind of like How It's Made
but more host on the ground.
Kind of exploring and experiencing
what's going on at these snack factories.
And then we were approached.
And when we were approached,
I think it's important
to kind of establish
the way that we see
opportunities like this right?
An opportunity to host a television show,
I would say 10 years ago it was like,
that's why we were in this game.
We were doing what we
were doing on YouTube
to try to.
Let's say 12 years ago.
Kind of launch into, yeah
'cause once GMM started.
Kind of launch into something
in the traditional space
but over the years what
we've built here at Mythical
and the stuff that we're producing
has become the priority for us.
So opportunities like this don't,
they no longer have this oh,
this is the thing that we've
always been waiting for,
we've always been wanting
and now we're gonna throw
all our time into this
and throw everything else away.
It's more like,
"Okay we're not going to stop
doing Good Mythical Morning,
"we're not gonna stop doing this podcast.
"We're not gonna stop doing all the things
"that we're doing in Mythical."
So the question is can we make this work?
Because it's not just a done deal
that it's automatically a good idea right?
We have been approached for other things
that we have said no to but
the condition for saying yes
to something like this was,
"We will do this if we
can be executive producers
"of the show and Mythical
can be a production entity
"on the show."
So in other words,
if we can make it our show
instead of just being plugged in
as hosts.
Now we were approached, not
by Food Network directly
but by the production company
that hatched the original idea
and got Food Network on
board and excited about it.
That production company is called B17.
They've produced a number of other shows.
You should check them out.
You should look 'em up.
So B17 approached us.
Yep.
And their executive over there,
his name is Rhett.
His name is Rhett.
I was like,
okay we have a connection.
He might be a DJ.
But maybe some confusion.
He may be a DJ.
No, he never brought that up.
I don't know, you don't know that.
People don't wear it on their sleeve.
Well if he did, he'd be called DJ Link.
True, okay.
That clears it up.
I thought about, I don't know.
How am I ever gonna tell you
that I've thought about other DJ names
because I just don't want to put it.
I just don't want to put too much energy
out there in the universe
about my aspirations.
I want it to be something that
just kind of never happens
or it just happens on my own terms.
So I'm gonna stop talking about
that.
Good.
But yes, and they had experience.
B17 had experience with making
shows with internet talent.
And we liked what they
had done, we liked them.
And the thing is is that
I kind of set it up
we're only gonna say yes
if we get to be the creative force
behind the show or whatever.
Made us sound like pills.
Well but the thing is is that.
But I don't think we were.
That's what B17 and Food Network wanted.
They were, yeah.
In other words it's like,
you don't want a host who's just like,
"I'm gonna come in here,
I'm gonna do my thing
"and I'm gonna leave."
You actually want somebody who's like,
"No, no, we want to be involved.
"We want to make this show our own.
"We want to be engaged.
"We want to be passionate
about this thing."
Yeah.
And also,
we're really, really, really busy
and we can devote about a
day to shooting an episode
just FYI.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And they wasn't like,
oh no we can't do that.
It was like, well okay actually
that's what we were thinking
too because you know,
with all the stuff that's being
made in the world right now,
they're not just throwing
out massive amounts
of money for the budgets
on these shows right?
It's like, people are trying to make shows
much more efficient than they used to.
So being able to produce
something in a day
or shoot something a
day is actually the page
that everybody was already on.
So then we started asking
the question of like,
all right, this loose concept of,
it totally makes sense why
they would approach us.
We've tried all this food.
We've eaten all these snacks.
We've kind of positioned
ourselves as your buddies
behind the desk who eat
all the stuff for you
to tell you if you should eat it.
Yeah people who taste
things and talk about it.
Right, not chefs.
If I didn't have to clarify that.
I didn't think I had to clarify that, yes.
Not chefs but food-adjacent,
or actually directly related to food
but not guys who make it.
Just guys who eat it.
Just like you.
Food friends.
And then the process
started it was like well.
Could've called it that, Food Friends.
Well we got close to calling it something.
That's true.
It was called something else
at one point.
We can get into that a little bit.
There was a couple of things happening
sort of behind the scenes
and so there was a desire
to differentiate this from just
kind of going into a factory
and just dealing with snacks.
It was like,
can we expand that into just
America's favorite food brands?
So that might be a restaurant.
It might be somebody
who makes this a snack
but just a food or a place that makes food
that everyone kind of knows and relates to
and has some sort of
point of reference to.
Yeah, which is kind of our mentality
on Good Mythical Morning.
The more we can pull from and
experience well-known brands,
whether that's fast food brands.
You know, sit down restaurant brands
or different types of
potato chips or cereals.
That are you know, stuff you
can find in the grocery store
or on the snack aisle.
Like there's that connection
that there's people
that are passionate about certain things
and we're very passionate
about certain things.
So tapping into that
passion and then saying,
"Okay, well let's peel back the curtain
"and show you behind the scenes there."
But there's so much more
than just that whole factory thing anyway.
That like, this show can be more expansive
and then it got more exciting.
And then we had the idea to like,
how do we sort of Rhett and
Linkize this thing in terms of
we knew that we wanted it to
be very comedy-forward right?
And we also knew that we wanted it to be
very curiosity-forward
because those are kind of
the two pillars of our brand.
Curiosity and comedy.
And so that was when we
established this idea
of what if there was
sort of an off the wall,
sort of out of left field
question that we want to ask
about this particular brand.
Like when we think Chipotle,
this is what we think.
When we think about Cheesecake Factory,
this is the question
that comes to mind for us
and then can we craft an
episode around that question
and kind of getting,
going behind the scenes
to answer that question.
Before Chipotle or Cheesecake Factory
became actual episodes,
do you remember the first
example we talked about?
I do remember 'cause I came
up with it in a phone call.
Yeah it was like you know,
we were having these
working meetings with B17.
Me, you,
Stevie and our development
executive at the time, Mallory.
We were kind of like shaping it.
It was fun and so we were coming up with,
I remember it was a very
preliminary conversation.
We were talking about
this line of questioning,
being inquisitive.
Right.
And could one question become like,
a starting point for an episode
or maybe a throughline for an episode
but when you're brainstorming,
when you speak in abstract terms,
you can only get so excited.
And so if in those moments,
on those like nascent calls we
can throw something out there
that you can rally around,
it makes all the difference in the world.
And so that's when you
threw out the example.
I don't remember how I
phrased the question.
I thought you said you remembered it.
No I know the question.
The question was about the foldy chip.
Yeah like say we're going
to a potato chip factory
to look at like, we're a big fan of Lay's.
Let's see if we could go to
a Lay's potato chip factory.
And I think the question was essentially,
how did the foldy chips happen
and how does this brand
feel about the foldy chips?
And that came from the fact
that you have talked about
how you like the foldy chips.
You prefer the foldy chips.
You go after the foldy chips.
I've even said I want a bag
of nothing but foldy chips.
And so I think.
And I ain't talking
about kettle cut,
Kettle chips.
And I think the question.
What I had in mind was is
the foldy chip a mistake
or is the foldy chip a beautiful mistake
or is the foldy chip?
Is it?
An accepted error
or is it part of the design?
Right.
And how,
yeah how do the executives?
How do the executive chefs
at the potato chip factory
or like the quality control people?
You know, we started
salivating over these answers.
Right.
And everybody on the call
got excited about it.
So that became the clarion call.
Yep.
Of the curiosity
associated with Inside Eats even though
we weren't calling it that yet.
And then of course, as
this was developing.
Now first of all, everybody
was like yes, this is great.
Now the process of,
I mean you gotta be making phone calls to,
B17 is reaching out to all these brands.
Because you gotta be like,
Hey these two guys.
Here you can go to their YouTube,
you can see who they are.
They're going to come to your place
and they're going to sort
of go behind the scenes
for this Food Network Show and I mean,
not everybody is comfortable
with us coming into their,
finding out about what they're
doing but in some ways.
I would say most brands
were excited about it
because I mean, let's just face it.
You're gonna be, after
you watch an episode,
you're gonna be hungry for
whatever this thing is.
But I mean you have to sell that
'cause the show doesn't
exist and you know,
there is a level of trust that a brand
has to put on the line
and it's so easy for,
especially when you go to
like corporatized brands.
Like someone as big as
Chipotle could easily have,
somebody's job's on the line.
And they could just want to
cover their own ass and say,
"Well there's just as much
to lose as there is to gain.
"What if these guys embarrass us?
"You know, I don't know
what exactly this show is.
"But it is Food Network and I do,
"I can see other things
these guys have done."
And you know,
B17 did a good job.
We're respect.
We're good boys.
We're not going to embarrass you too much.
I mean we've talked some food on our show
just because hey, you gotta be honest
about what you like.
You gotta stay honest.
But yeah luckily some
very high profile brands
like Chipotle's huge you know?
To see, to get the vision for it and say,
"Hey, this could be great for
us and everybody could win."
And we had to find four brands,
just to give you a little
background on this.
So.
Right.
Season one of Inside
Eats is four episodes.
I mean four episodes, that's a short.
That's just, that's how Discovery
or Food Network is doing things right now.
It's like first episode, first season,
let's do four episodes,
see what people think.
At least they didn't order a pilot
and then maybe we work on
that and then no one sees it.
Yeah.
If they don't like it,
it's like, they're gonna make an order.
I feel like it's kind of an extended pilot
'cause four is a short season.
But I think it's,
you really learn a lot
as we'll talk about.
Yeah.
That then you can
really take it, take all that into account
when they order more.
And I certainly hope they do.
Yeah, well 'cause we learned.
We'll get into how much we've learned
in just doing the first four but,
so the brands that responded.
Actually more than a
handful of brands responded
and said they were into the idea
and the four that ended up
working out based on timing.
Because this all had to happen.
This moved very quickly
and it had to happen at the end of 2021.
We shot all four episodes over
the course of about two weeks
in literally, like I said,
four actual days of shooting.
Like two days in a row and
then like two weeks later
two more days.
Right before Christmas.
And the companies that we ended
up going with were Chipotle,
Cheesecake Factory, Coolhaus ice cream
which is a very cool ice cream shop.
That actually is available nationwide.
You probably have seen
them at the grocery store
but they're based in L.A..
Their pint's
next to like Ben & Jerry's.
And then Beyond Meat who we've
talked about on the show.
You know basically making
plant-based meat products
and they had never had anybody
enter behind the scenes.
But anyway,
those are the four that
are featured in season one.
And for the first episode,
since that's the one that
you can watch right now.
The thing that we talked about
'cause this is something that
we've sort of talked about
tangentially before is this like,
when you go to Chipotle.
Are you a burrito guy?
Are you a bowl girl?
Are you a quesadilla kid?
Whatever, I'm not saying
that that's who gets those things.
I'm just you.
Are you a salad robot?
Yeah and we wanted to ask the question,
does what you order at
Chipotle say something
about your personality and
maybe more specifically,
does your personality,
can we know things about your personality
and then predict what you're
going to get at Chipotle?
Yeah and at least, in
the least we thought,
"Well it'll be fun to try."
Yes.
And it was.
So very much in the same way
that we approach things on GMM where
we delve into research and science
but we do it from a comedic
standpoint, that is,
that's really how we approach the show.
Especially that first episode
'cause it was kind of a
social science question.
Yeah for Cheesecake Factory,
we knew we had to make the episode
ultimately about the
bigness of their menu.
How could their menu be so large?
Like why?
But also how?
If you think about it.
It's a crazy amount of dishes
to come out of one kitchen
that then is replicated in
all their different locations.
It's pretty wild.
And then for Coolhaus, because they had.
I mean arguably pushed the
flavors of ice cream just as far,
if not farther than any
other ice cream maker,
I mean that inspired us to say,
"Well how far is too far?"
And would they let us
develop our own ice creams?
To answer the question,
how far can you push ice cream flavor?
What is the limit that you can push it to?
When have you crossed a threshold?
'Cause you know, we're
willing to cross it.
Just dance all over that line.
And each other's graves if they, you know.
Right.
Whoever loses
the competition.
And then in Beyond Meat the
question was essentially,
what is?
What is this process that leads to
them being able to make
something that is so meat-like
and something we were very
specifically interested in
is don't you have to still
have a familiarity with meat?
And like understand meat
and sort of like meat?
Because what Beyond Meat is trying to do,
they're actually making a product for
people who like to eat meat
but would like to have a meat alternative.
Either sometimes or
eventually all the time.
Yeah, but if not for.
You're not trying
to create.
Health reasons
or dietary reasons, for
environmental reasons.
Right, so they actually.
They're banking on the fact that humans
generally like the taste and
texture and color of meat.
But not everybody wants to
eat that much actual meat.
So how do you do that
in a plant-based way?
And for me personally, I mean I enjoyed,
legitimately enjoyed the
process at every single place.
The Beyond Meat episode
for me was the one,
it just gets very scientific.
It gets.
Yeah it was.
It gets very specific
and like oh that's,
this is how it happens?
There was a lot of surprise and awe.
But there was also, for that episode,
because this is all proprietary stuff.
Like and they had never let anybody in.
They'd never let cameras in
their headquarters before.
Right.
And so there was like,
a woman who's like looking
at whatever's in the frame
and making sure there's not
some secret formula in the back.
Because there's competition out
there with plant-based meats
and so we got a lot of information
but we didn't get enough
where you could be like,
"I'm gonna start my own Beyond Meat now."
No, we got all the information
but then at the very end there was that
Men In Black moment, do you remember?
Oh yes, yeah.
On the way out?
I think that just like a Tussy deodorant
that somebody held up in front of us.
A Tussy deodorant.
You know Tussy?
Tussy.
Tussy the deodorant.
That's my favorite brand of anything.
And it kind of is
like circular.
T-U-S-S-Y.
Tussy.
Well the great thing about
Tussy is that we can.
Can we do an Inside Eats on Tussy?
Well I hope so.
Can we talk about how I
used to take a Sharpie?
No.
And change the T to a P?
No, no.
We do not, you do not eat Tussy.
It's a deodorant.
Can you eat Tussy?
Okay.
On season two of.
Inside.
I won't even say it.
I won't even.
I'm not even gonna say it man.
So we're,
we're deciding that this
is gonna be our approach.
Let's move to actually
filming these things
'cause it was you know,
first of all, coming out of the pandemic.
There was, I mean still a
lot of safety protocols.
A lot of masks being
worn up until the second
of us actually being on camera.
Lots of testing happening.
Super safetyness.
Well I wanna talk about the team
that was kind of working
behind the scenes as well
to kind of make it where when we showed up
everything was gonna go
as seamless as possible.
Our showrunner TJ
Chambers who is you know,
I would say more so than us,
the hardest working person
in this whole endeavor right?
I mean that dude worked his ass off
to help make this show happen.
Yeah.
'Cause he's basically
worrying about everything
from the very beginning to the very end
of like delivering the trailer.
Oh yeah, shaping.
You know.
And protecting the tone of the show
and really shepherding our wishes
and the network's wishes
and creating something that
is not a compromise but is
the best of both worlds.
Yeah and he's kind of a jack of all trades
in a lot of ways because he is a writer.
You know, he's a writer, he's a producer.
He's a director.
There's a lot of things that are happening
behind the scenes and then
when we're producing it.
He needs more of, yeah like
lots of comedy experience.
Because what we knew we wanted right,
because our experience
with Commercial Kings
and if you go back and
watch Commercial Kings
as Link asked you to do earlier,
which I guess is on Amazon.
Yeah, Amazon steaming.
You'll see
there was a very specific convention
that we used back then called OTF.
On the fly interviews.
So the way that we would,
the way that we should shoot
that show is we would go,
we would work with a business,
we would make the commercial
and then we would kind of.
All along the way.
Take stock.
Take stock of like what just happened
and can we just stand you guys
in front of this building right here
and ask you some questions so you can,
looks like a reality show.
Just like they do on The
Batchelor or Survivor or whatever.
Yeah or every HDTV show.
You would just talk
about what is happening
and we'll use.
In the present tense.
We'll use that to sort of
piece the story together.
We knew that we did not want to do that
for like seven different reasons.
Number one, I don't like that convention.
I feel like.
It's done a lot.
It's kind of overdone
but also it traps you into
whatever you said in that moment.
It ends up seeming kind of canned.
We like voiceover.
We like being able to
look at what we have done,
look at what has been created,
look at the footage that we actually have
and then make decisions
about how we want to piece it together
and it's also an opportunity
to really nail the comedy
and change jokes
because you're not gonna go
back out to that building
and stand in front of it again.
Oh God.
But you can just
simply voiceover something different.
Well on Commercial Kings
we were really burned
because we got into the edit
process and we were like,
"We really need to cut
to an interview guys
"introducing the next thing
"or bridging from idea A to idea B."
And it was a lot of heavy lifting
from a story standpoint that
then we just had to go out
into some nondescript
North Hollywood location
from our edit bays and spend a few hours
just standing out there.
Yeah.
Acting like we were back.
In Nevada.
In Nevada or Reno or I guess,
we went to other places besides Nevada.
Reno is in Nevada, Tonopah.
And it just, it was a lot
of work and it wasn't,
and it's not our best work
you know?
No no no no.
It's really hard to do.
Especially as two people because.
We ended up scripting them and
that's when it got, just so
that we could get it done.
And you could tell.
And then it was like.
And with a voiceover,
knowing that it's scripted
is just everyone knows.
Of course yeah you guys
are now reading this thing
that you've written.
It's narration, of course.
And it's more of an acceptable convention
and more flexible, all those things.
But we actually.
Best decision we ever made
for the show.
We brought Nick Lopez.
If you're like a hardcore
GMM trivia enthusiast
you might know that Nick was,
well first of all.
I am not.
We got to know Nick 'cause
Nick was a writer's assistant
on Buddy System season two.
Two, yep.
And we loved him, hired him
onto the GMM writing team.
Yep.
He quickly,
I think he was a writer's
at some point on GMM.
Quickly moved into a head
writer position and but he so.
Went to work on other projects.
So talented he's had the opportunity
to kind of just move on to other things
and work on other things but we were like,
"He'll come back and work
on GMM from time to time
"when we need an extra hand."
But we were like, and
I think it was Stevie.
Stevie's idea was like,
"Oh we should talk to Nick."
Because the show.
He understands our voice.
The show is not written per se
but if you're gonna go into,
like oh we're going into this situation
where there's the guy who
is the head chef at Chipotle
and we're gonna be asking
a bunch of questions.
Nick is able to be like,
here are some paths that you can go down.
Here are some conversational
paths you can go down.
Here's something that
you might want to ask.
Here's a little fun fact that
you might want to bring up.
Here's something that I know that he knows
because we got it from a pre-interview
that you might find a way to
reveal in the conversation.
Like you can get at this in a funny way.
So Nick did a lot of work
there along with TJ to kind of,
when we got to set on that first day
which Chipotle was the
first episode that we shot
as a matter of fact.
Yeah.
I'll just say
I had a, my back.
You know this is what
happens a lot of with me
when we're moving into a project.
That's right.
My lower back goes out
and it's just something that
I haven't quite get a hold on
and I don't know why it always happens
but my back.
Stress.
Yeah, well I know that's why it happens
but I don't know specifically.
I don't know how the mechanically
all this stuff happens.
But my back had seized up
and it was like a nine
on a scale of one to 10
in terms of how
bad my back my back can hurt.
I felt for you man.
So whenever you see Rhett walking.
That whole episode my back is.
He's walking fine.
I am in extreme pain
that whole episode.
But I will hand it to myself.
I did a good job of setting,
like compartmentalizing the pain
in terms of when we were in a conversation
and just being in the moment
and trying to be in a comedic head space.
That sucks man.
But you definitely can tell.
I mean it's akin to like,
almost like a migraine almost you know?
Migraines are worse.
Migraines are worse but
it's almost.
When the head is,
when the pain is localized
in your face, in your head
which feels like the
center of your person,
I think that's a lot more
disrupting than like.
Yeah.
My lower back is killing me
right now but I'm still up here.
Your face can be happy.
I can go completely
into my head and just exist in my head
like that brain on Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Yeah, Krang.
Yeah.
That's basically,
I was embodying or
channeling, Crane is his name?
Krang, Krang.
Krang, yeah.
You did good Rhett.
And I was using the Krang
voice the whole time
if that helps explain it.
I was not in any pain.
I had some jitters you know?
It's like okay we're dusting off the,
well the dust.
Not only of the pandemic
but like experiencing
an entire new crew and in
a place where it's like,
we're just starting this thing.
Everybody's watching closely
from a protocol COVID standpoint
to like a performance,
to like what is this show gonna be
to the network standpoint.
But I think one of the main things that
I feel great about with this show
and I felt it very early on.
The first time we shot
something was that first scene.
First thing we shot was around back.
This guy pulls up
and he's unloading all
of the raw materials.
The vegetables and the chicken
and stuff for Chipotle.
So when you see this,
just so you know when you
watch this on the show.
This is probably halfway or
maybe even a little longer
than halfway through the episode
when we approach this
guy unloading the stuff
in the truck behind the Chipotle.
First thing we shot.
That was literally,
we were doing our hair and
makeup inside the Chipotle
that we were shooting at.
Right.
And then they were like, okay
this is your first scene.
Because again, everything has to be shot
according to when things are happening
and then later it's pieced together
to make a consistent narrative.
So yeah us walking around that corner
making that Law and Order
joke was the very first thing
we shot with Inside Eats.
Yeah and we were like,
"We got a couple of questions for you."
And he's like, "How are you doing?"
It's like, "Oh you're gonna
start with the questions."
And it was all right, we're in the mix.
Things are, this is happening.
And we were off to the races.
It felt, it felt great
to say at the end of that first day
or even halfway through the first day
that my main concern had
been alleviated which was
are we gonna be in our zone?
Are we going to be this,
ourselves.
Ourselves.
Are we gonna be comfortable, confident
and having a good time?
Are we gonna take everything
that we've learned
from Good Mythical Morning and
even when things would change
over the years with Good Mythical Morning.
The bigger the change,
the more chance that all of a
sudden, our vibe would be off.
And when everything is new,
your brain, my brain tends to focus.
It doesn't yet know what to
tune out and what to focus on.
Oh there's new people in the crew.
There's new cameras, it's cold today.
I'm wearing something different.
I'm this, that and the other.
Your back hurts.
All of these type of variables.
You have to know what to tune
out and what to focus on.
To just, to be the most,
to be true to ourselves.
And just trust our instincts
and be in that moment.
Well.
And I was very, very happy
that this show is you know,
we were never put in a position
and we never stepped
into a position that was,
that stretched us in a way
that wasn't a good idea.
For me, that.
Just because the people
that we were working with
had very clearly communicated
that they understood
what makes us who we are
and they wanted us to be who we are.
Yeah.
So I don't think
I ever felt any.
There was never a question
in my mind of like,
are we gonna be put into
the right circumstance
to pull this off?
It was more like, you know there's this.
We are always doing this
little dance you know?
We had watched.
The most analogous thing
to this in the recent past
is The Backup Plan series
that we did on GMN.
Right.
That was sponsored by Geico.
Yeah when we went to the cereal factory
and got in the.
Right.
So we actually.
The huge cereal bowl
is a great example.
We sent those, we sent that
episode of the cereal bowl
and there was another one where we went to
oh the.
The flavor.
The smell, the flavor factory.
We sent those over to
B17 and TJ and everybody
and we were like.
You know we've done this
type of thing before
and this is sort of the vibe right?
We're asking a real question
but we're doing it in a ridiculous way.
There's gonna be these ridiculous asides
and we're obviously entering
the situation as a comedy duo.
I hadn't watched those in years
and I remember watching them.
And I remember that night I watched them
and immediately sent those
two episodes to you and Stevie
'cause I was like hey, I didn't
know how I was gonna feel.
You never know how you're
gonna feel about something
when you go back to it years later.
Yeah.
'Cause you always feel like
you've developed beyond it or whatever.
Yeah.
I was like hey, this is the.
This is the true north.
The way that we interacted here.
This is how we.
This is the vibe that
we should attain right?
This is the vibe we should go for.
Yeah.
And I think we really got there.
I mean there's always a little bit,
it depends on what
we're doing at the time.
There are moments in this type of format
where we get to a place where me and you
are standing there talking to one person
and asking them questions
and not doing something.
And it gets to be like two
guys interviewing two person
and since nothing is scripted.
Again like yes we had this notebook
that's like here's some
questions you could ask.
Here's what this person knows.
Here is the goal of this scene.
We had all kind of developed
that and then Nick and TJ
had put it in this big
binder that we were given
when we got on set so
we reorient ourselves
but when the camera starts rolling,
you don't remember what the binder said.
You remember bits and pieces of it
but you're really going on instinct.
Yeah.
And so you've got
what you're thinking.
I've got what I'm thinking.
Oh, Link just said that.
I'm gonna go with that or
that makes me think this.
I'm gonna get out of his way for a second.
There is this debt.
There's a balance in trying to
figure out that dance again.
Yeah the brain gets hot.
There's a lot going on.
But it pretty much came back immediately.
It wasn't like a struggle.
Yeah, very glad about that.
So I think you know,
so when we were bringing
our comedic sensibility
and our curiosity to the
table and to every scene,
having structured the episodes
and gotten approval on that.
The thing that Food
Network was bringing to us
was an education on their
expectations from their audience
'cause this is a melding
of two audiences you know?
Between a Food Network,
Discovery+ and Mythical Beasts.
And I would
say specifically.
And I would like
to talk about that.
I would say
specifically Food Network which yes,
Food Network is a part of Discovery
but when we got approached,
we actually didn't know.
I don't know if I missed
it or if it developed later
but we didn't know that it
was a Food Network show.
The conversation was Discovery+.
Right.
So,
I knew it was gonna be food-centric
because that's the whole point of the show
but the moment that it either became
or I finally realized.
We didn't know if it
would be comedy-centric with food
but it became.
Well there's a, yeah.
Clear that it needed to be food-centric.
Right, and when we say
food-centric, what we mean is that.
So a person who has decided
to turn on Food Network
and maybe you're one of those people.
If you're like me,
you're just the kind of
person that just likes
to look at food right?
You like to look at food
and see people make food
and see people eat food
because you have a love affair with food.
It's probably the best thing on earth
besides what rhymes with Tussy.
Okay.
That we talked
about earlier.
And so people who watch Food Network,
they need to see food.
Right, they don't just want
to see two guys being stupid,
being funny.
Yeah.
Because if you're a Food Network first,
if you're tuning in for Food Network first
and not Rhett and Link first.
You're like I'm here for the
food part of the network.
I don't want these two guys
to get in the way of the food.
And so there was one guy
who had a sort of specialized camera.
It was a different camera
that could do a really high
frame rate for slow motion.
And he was the food camera guy.
Yeah.
And so if the guacamole
is being made or dipped out of something
or steak is being chopped,
it's being like that's when
those sort of hero shots
or whatever you want to call them,
slow-mo, sort of dramatic food shots.
He was getting all,
and as he was getting all this footage.
Me, not really understanding the show
that we were making yet, I was like,
"Wow, he's filming a lot,
he's filming all this food.
"But I mean it's gonna
be us on camera right?"
You know it was like,
I mean if we're gonna be the
funny guys on camera right.
So there was a realignment that happened
in terms of like understanding the,
where everything should settle.
What the balance should be for this show
and really begin to understand
and getting that Food
Network education that hey,
the audience wants to
indulge with their eyes.
You know?
And you can,
yeah we can have fun all along the way.
But you want to indulge
and you want to learn.
So as we were in the post-phase
of editing everything together
and we were giving a bunch of
notes about like all right,
I remember saying this
and we had, it was funny.
Or I remember Rhett said this,
they're like there's
three things from Rhett.
There's nothing from me.
Let's have a little bit
more balance or vice versa.
We would give these type of notes.
Right.
Or this is a runner.
I think we have a throwback.
You know comedy notes.
Yeah the thing that we're interested in.
And the Food Network notes would be like,
we need to understand more of the process.
You started making the guacamole
but we don't know what the final,
you didn't reveal what
the final ingredient was.
It didn't come together.
It's like you gotta have.
If you're gonna go into
this guacamole moment,
well it needs to have a
beginning, middle and end.
You gotta have a satisfying conclusion
so that people feel like
they've got the full guac experience
and it totally makes sense.
And you want to,
and you want to see the guac
and hey if there's a fact
about how many avocados
Chipotle goes through in a year or a week
or whatever that fact was.
That's an interesting thing.
We didn't ask that in scene
but we can pull a voiceover.
We can change that.
And whenever you start
to learn these things,
well now let's add another layer
where we're doing some animations
that illustrate the things
that you're learning
from a culinary standpoint.
And I think the point.
And so that was added
to the show.
I think the point of this,
like what I am hoping that you listening
will take from this
discussion is you know,
if we made this show and we were making it
for the Good Mythical Morning audience.
Right.
We were going into Chipotle
and asking this question
and then putting it on
to an episode of GMM
or as an episode of GMM
like we do with The Backup Plan.
Because you're tuning in
to Good Mythical Morning
we think primarily to hang out with us,
then it's gonna be almost like 90 to 95%
just us being us and using
this canvas of Chipotle
as an opportunity to be funny right?
Yeah.
But because
the intended audience
is first and foremost
is someone who's interested
in food television,
Food Network.
It is a food show first
that we are then bringing all that
Rhett and Link ridiculousness
and curiosity into.
To kind of create more of a balance.
So while I do think it is the most,
I don't wanna say it's the
funniest show on Food Network.
I mean I think Guy Fieri is very funny
but I think it the most
intentionally comedic show
on Food Network.
And shout out to Alton Brown
who we still want to have on GMM.
Yeah yeah yeah.
You know he did more
like this sketch thing
at the top of his show.
Well one of his shows and you know,
that's another thing that we did succeed
at starting with comedy.
Like there's basically
a sketch.
Well let me clarify
real quick.
I just made it sound like I was saying
that Guy Fieri is unintentionally funny.
No, I'm just saying that like,
he's coming in there first
and foremost as a chef
who happens to be very funny.
We're coming in as comedians
who just happen to some knowledge about,
experience with food.
Oh I got you.
You know what I'm saying?
I got you.
But yeah, I am curious at this.
You know we're talking to you
and kind of telling you
what our perspective is.
And all of this I think has come together
in a show that makes the most sense.
That is satisfying on all
of these levels you know?
Are there as many jokes as we made?
Of course not.
There's lots of stuff that got cut.
But there are more just so you know.
Again, when you're doing linear television
that's actually gonna
show up on Food Network
and have commercial breaks.
That episode is about 22
minutes of content right?
That's how much content ends up being
in a half hour block of
traditional television.
So you've gotta hit 22 minutes.
Obviously on Discovery+,
streaming service,
you don't have to hit that.
So we had these additional,
sometimes a completely new scene
and sometimes just a new
thing that happened in a scene
and all those have been added in
when you watch it on Discovery+.
So you might get like a 25, 26
minute episode on Discovery+
and most of that's gonna be stuff
that wasn't essential
or integral to a Food Network audience.
So it tends to be some of
the funny tangential stuff
that happened in the moment.
The thing that I'm most
interested in at this point,
because it hasn't premiered
yet as of this recording.
Is yeah, what is the reception gonna be?
What, what are Mythical
Beasts going to think of it?
What is the Food Network
audience gonna think?
How are we going to find out
what non Mythical Beasts think?
Oh.
We are gonna get
that feedback?
I'm sure we'll find that out.
You know?
It's like we'll have
to go to other places,
other ways that the show is posted online.
Or promos of it are posted online.
Just to you know, tap into
that buzz but I'm just,
I'm interested because again,
it's like every time you put something out
for a new type of audience it's like,
well are they gonna
hate one or both of us?
Well there's.
And I just know,
you know I just, I know that
with the way that I do things.
It's like, I'm not for everybody.
I'm not for everybody.
So I'm kind of prepared for that.
It's like, and I.
But I don't, and if that's the reason
the show doesn't work, so be it.
Well I could.
The show ain't gonna
work without me.
I'll just have to do season two alone.
Well this is your -
Or maybe I oughta do it
with DJ Rhett.
No this is your opportunity to say,
people don't like me either.
That's true, a lot of
people don't like me.
Maybe more people than don't like you.
Right.
But so there's a question
of like is the traditional
Food Network audience
going to be like,
"I want to see somebody
who's making great food.
"I don't want to see a couple of idiots
"who are just having fun with food."?
And then on the opposite
end of the spectrum,
are there people who are like,
"I'm just coming here
for the ridiculousness
"of Rhett and Link
"and I don't care about
all the food shots."?
Because we have made a show
that is a compromise between
what both parties want.
I believe that, I mean for me,
because I do like food a lot
and I like food facts and
I like to see the process.
It was fascinating to get to know
the people who are making the decisions
about what ends up on the Chipotle menu
or The Cheesecake Factory menu.
The people behind these
incredible flavors at Coolhaus.
The scientists, the flavor scientists
behind Beyond Meat.
Yeah.
That's all super fascinating stuff to me.
That's personally more
fascinating than me making a joke.
So I feel like it landed in a great place.
I do too.
I'm very proud of this show.
I was very proud of Commercial Kings
and if we had the opportunity.
If they had ordered more,
we would've turned a corner
and it would've gotten that much better.
But the core of that show was
something I'm very proud of
and I wish they would've ordered more.
I'm glad that they didn't
because Good Mythical Morning
may have never existed
and we wouldn't be here today.
But we learned so much
in these four episodes.
Yeah.
Of figuring out
what the show is and how
to ask those questions
and what we should actually be shooting
and the things that we
should actually be doing
that I feel like,
I'm not saying there's.
We have so much more focus.
I'm not saying there's anything,
I think where we ended up with season one
after a lot of edits and
a lot of back and forth
and figuring that out.
We kind of know exactly what the mode is
and what the final
project is gonna be going,
if we can go into a second season.
Where I would just be
that much more confident
to make a great television show.
But we've experienced
enough to know that like,
you know it could go either way.
We're very hopeful.
We believe that this show has legs
and we want to keep making it.
But you know, there's so many factors.
Yeah.
Not the least of which is
who, again at this point,
who knows how it will be interpreted?
How we will be interpreted
within the Food Network programming.
Yeah.
That's just very,
'cause it is, it is a
different type of show
that pushes the comedy more
and it is, it's unique.
So that's a good thing if
enough people are ready for it.
If they have, pun intended,
an appetite for it.
Now I haven't really come,
I haven't made a definitive
decision about this
but I am considering and
strongly leaning toward
not reading anything about the show.
Not looking at anyone's
thoughts about the show.
We've never done that
with anything we've made.
Why would you start now?
I'm getting much more.
Actually, I am moving in that
direction much, much more.
I find it to be a much healthier place.
Because while the vast majority
of the feedback that we get
on the things that we do is positive
because we've got such
a supportive fanbase.
First of all you know
that the minority comments
who are gonna say something hurtful,
those are the ones that you remember.
But also I find myself not
being in a healthy place
when I'm trying to find
the positive comments.
Yeah.
To outweigh
the negative comments and then I realize
that I am finding my identity and my value
in other people's
interpretation of my work.
Where what I'm trying
to do is get to a place
where I am happy with
what this ended up being
and so that's the only
thing that I need to know.
Is that I am proud of it.
I know what I like about it,
what I don't like about it.
My thoughts about it, what
I would do differently.
Now we have people who
are here at Mythical
who are going to tell us the
aggregate opinions of people
which are very helpful.
I'm not saying
I don't want to take the
audience's reception into account
because you're not a good
producer if you don't do that.
If you don't know what
the audience thinks.
But there is something
that happens emotionally
and mentally when you interact directly
with either a compliment or a criticism.
That I don't think is
necessarily good for my psyche.
Well, I applaud that.
I actually think talking
out both sides of my mouth
'cause I said that we've
never done that before
but the more I think about it,
I read stuff less and less.
Like I'm kind of a, what's the?
I'm a hermit in.
I'm like a social media hermit.
I mean, you tell me lots of
things that I don't read.
That they never crossed my path.
Yeah.
So actually,
you're a lot more prone to it than I am.
I think I'll probably end up
just being like, you know.
I didn't end up reading anything.
Well it's things like.
But a new project is.
I can be having a good.
Your friend
and like the ongoing stuff.
I can be having a good day
and then I make the horrible
decision to go and look at,
I mean I haven't done this recently.
I'm just saying back when it
was a relevant thing to do.
Look at the Goodreads reviews for
"The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek".
Now first of all, again.
The aggregate of that book
and the rating is very high right?
I'm proud of that book.
Obviously we're not novelists
and I didn't think it was gonna be,
like win the Pulitzer Prize
and we learned a lot in doing it.
But I'm proud of what it
ended up being for what it is.
But there are people who come to Goodreads
who see themselves as literary critics
and then just write these scathing reviews
and some of them you're like,
"Well yeah that's true."
Or yeah, you're right about that.
That puts me in,
but I already know what I
think about that process.
I already know how I feel about that book.
I already know how I feel about
what we would do differently
if we were to do a
second one in the series
or whatever.
Yep.
So you're not learning anything.
I'm only suffering emotionally.
So as I try to release myself
from things that I can't control
which is people's opinions about our work,
what I can't control is our work right?
I have an opinion about it
and that opinion can be incorporated
into the next iteration
and it just feels like
a much healthier place.
So because of all the things
that you were just saying about,
yes there's gonna be people
who are like, actively,
I don't want this on my network.
I don't want these YouTube
idiots on my network.
For whatever reason, for
hangups that they have
or they just, like you
said, they don't like us.
They don't like our sense of humor.
It's stupid, whatever.
They don't like the
fact that you're picky.
They don't like the fact
that we're not chefs.
Feeling that they don't
like my hair, whatever.
I already know that there's
people who think that.
I already know that there are people
who think we're insufferable.
Do I need to hear them say it?
So.
We also don't need them
to change their mind.
Right.
We're doing just fine.
Yeah and so that's what
I'm saying ultimately is,
I don't think.
I'm definitely not gonna
seek out any sort of,
I heard somebody saying one time,
"Never read your book review.
"Never read your movie review."
If we ever have the privilege
of making a feature-length movie,
I don't think I'm gonna
read any critic reviews.
Whoa.
I don't think
I'm gonna go to Rotten Tomatoes.
Now I'm gonna know what
the aggregate score is
because you can't avoid it
and somebody's gonna tell us.
It's gonna be in some report
that comes in an email.
Everyone, your movie exists.
It is currently at a 61.
So it's sort of on fresh but just barely
and most of the comments
about the choice you guys made
to include the scene where the dog dies
and you really shouldn't have done that
or whatever you know?
And so and it was like yeah,
we shouldn't have put that in there.
Yeah I don't wanna overstate it either.
I don't wanna be like,
I'm just saying it like,
what I've noticed a number
of times is I'll be like,
"Things are good right now."
And then all of a sudden I'm
reading something and then.
I just know what the weakness is.
Those things.
I'm not saying
it ruins my day.
I'm saying that.
Those things
that you mentioned are
things that we already know.
People are gonna be opinionated
about the way we look,
the way that I act.
Our non-chef.
Like there's, yeah.
There's some targets on our
back if you want to be critical.
But those are things
that I don't want to change about myself.
The things that really hurt
are the things where
we know it's a weakness
and we wish we could've changed it.
Like that's when it really
gets me is that like.
Yeah, but I think there's.
But I guess what I'm
saying ultimately.
There are some
of those things but those are small.
When it comes to these four episodes,
there's not any gaping shortcoming.
Yeah, yeah I agree.
That I feel is like a big weakness.
It is what it is.
I agree with that.
I mean it's not, you know again it's not.
I mean we're not.
I was, honestly it's like,
are we trying to win an Emmy?
No.
No, of course not.
I mean maybe eventually
but we don't think that this show is
gonna do that.
No it's like,
I mean some of my favorite shows ever,
I don't know if they ever won an Emmy.
Right.
Did Dirty Jobs
ever win an Emmy?
Yeah so.
Maybe, I don't know.
I think it deserves one.
I completely agree with you
that the stuff that I
already know to be true.
It's like this person thinks this thing
and they perceive us in this way.
That's not the stuff that bothers me.
The stuff that bothers me
is the stuff that I
already know to be the case
that's like yes, we made this mistake
or we did this thing wrong
and now people are
basically recognizing that
and my worst fear of people finding out
that we made this mistake and
did this in the wrong way.
It's coming true.
Right.
What I'm saying is from
an emotional standpoint,
I already know the
mistakes that I've made.
And I'm not talking about with this.
I agree with you.
I don't feel that way about this show.
I'm just saying in general,
with the things that
we put into the world.
I have just found that
I'm in a healthier place
when I'm like you know what was lacking
about that thing that you did.
Do you need somebody to tell
you when you already know?
And do you gain anything
emotionally from it?
So if I can have somebody
else read all that feedback
and then come to us and be like,
"Hey this is actually
how things were received
"from a whole group."
That's much less emotionally unsettling
than reading individual people
say very personal things.
So I'm not saying I can't deal with it.
I'm just saying after it
happens, I think to myself,
"I could have not.
"I could have not experienced that
"and I would be having
a better time right now.
"I would be in a healthier place."
Yeah I get it.
This is not a GMM 22 scenario.
Oh.
I mean you know that.
Of course.
I think that's my point.
Yeah.
You know it's like,
we did that First We Feast snacked video
and I read those comments and
you get the people who don't,
they're not fans of ours.
Who maybe don't have a point
of reference for us and yeah,
I do remember the comment
about me that was like,
"This guy just, he like, he acts and eats
"like a four-year-old."
It's like okay, well.
That's, he's,
this commenter's describing something.
That could've hurt my
feelings but the thing I'm,
the way I'm trying to
grow is to interact with,
not interact with the comment.
But to acknowledge the
comment within myself as,
"You know what?
"He's describing something
that people are attracted to
"about my sense of humor and my persona."
Yeah.
That he doesn't get.
Or doesn't prefer.
And it's not for everybody.
And you know what?
So I mean, but I was fully myself
and I'm very proud of it
and I don't expect everybody to like me
and I'm cool with that.
And I actually remember thinking.
Just trying to be cool with that.
That's a good example
because I remember
thinking that when we left
that First We Feast shoot.
That I was like a four-year-old?
Yeah.
I remember thinking,
we were really ourselves
and we were having a genuinely good time
just being ourselves and
interacting with these snacks
and I am proud of what we did.
The only thing I was pissed about
was they didn't buy the right cereal.
So that's why there was
no cereal in the episode
and they also cut your beans.
They edited it out.
I did have baked beans
and that was edited out.
So just for the record,
Rhett ate beans and I ordered cereal
but Raisin Bran is not Raisin
Bran Crunch and that's not.
And by the way, Raisin Bran
is not Raisin Nut Bran.
Okay.
And that's the one I actually ordered
'cause I'm on that kick now.
Raisin Nut Bran Crunch?
Nope.
Or just Raisin Nut Bran?
Raisin Nut Bran.
Not Raisin Bran Crunch.
But so.
And I was pissed about that
but you know, mistakes are made and.
And I knew when we came as a duo.
It really isn't a big deal.
When we came as a duo and
we had all those snacks,
I knew that something
was gonna be cut out.
But what I'm getting at is,
even though I did, when it came out.
I did start scrolling
through the comments.
I stopped because I was like,
"Hold on, you remember
walking out of there
"and thinking to yourself,
"'You did that the way
that you wanted to do it.'"
Now any time you venture outside
of your protective bubble of your.
Mythical Beast.
Your Mythical Beasts.
You know that you're ready for,
you're gonna get some criticism.
And so again, I was like,
yes people aren't gonna like it.
Some people just look at us
and are immediately annoyed.
I understand, I get it.
I know people like that too.
Right.
But if I'm happy
with what I did and how I came across,
then I should just let that be
what I found the satisfaction in.
Not that somebody liked
it or didn't like it.
Again 'cause I don't want to just
hear things that people like either.
I'm saying that finding any sort of value
or currency in people liking
me or feeling undervalued
because people don't like me.
I'm just trying to move to
a new level of existence
and it's really difficult for a performer
who has built a career.
Oh yeah.
On trying to please an audience.
It's just part of the ongoing struggle.
So when we've got something
like this, that's again.
I don't know how many people
are going to watch the show
compared to how many people
watch Good Mythical Morning.
I think less given how many people
But it's still going to be
perceived as some leveling up.
It's like the people back
home in North Carolina,
oh they're all excited about the TV show
because it means more to them.
Because they think that
being on television
instead of having a YouTube show
is like a fundamentally
different, more awesome thing.
It's just how people think about things.
So you feel like you're
stepping up onto some sort of
pseudo-pedestal and now
people are gonna be like,
"Well now that they've done this,
"now I've gotta have my opinion."
And I'm just like,
"Well I already know what
I think about what we did.
"I already know about the show.
"So I should not even hear your opinion."
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
I got a little rec for ya.
If you want to do some easy listening,
I played this for you the other night.
Jose Gonzalez.
Yeah, I like him.
He is Swedish.
Well he's from Sweden but he's.
That's what I thought from the name.
His parents are Argentinian?
I was like, that sounds
like a Swedish name.
He's of Argentinian descent
but he was born and raised
in Sweden and he's got this,
this just totally soothing,
just going in nature and
listen to some Jose Gonzalez.
His last, his most recent album.
Where's my phone?
Got so many pockets in this suit.
It's in your pocket DJ Rhett.
It's not, it's my top pocket.
Listen to his album Local Valley.
Just to get some good
bucolic vibes going on.
Man, an introspective and autumnal folk
and indie pop blend.
That's pastoral in experience.
Jose Gonzalez, he's got a lot of albums.
You're welcome.
#EarBiscuits, let's keep
the conversation going.
We will talk with you
next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.